two dice are rolled a three appears on
at least one of the dice
find the probability that the sum of the
uppermost faces is greater
than seven okay now there's a bit of
interpretation
to deal with here actually there's
always interpretation to deal with but
some of the
phrasings and some questions are more
obscure than others
the question i got was that that second
sentence
a three appears on at least one of the
dice does that mean
like you know he's he's my um
he's my die you know right if i've got a
three
on this side does that count as
appearing on the dialect am i not am i
not just interested in the top now
i can tell you right now that's um
that's pretty fiendishly complicated i
can tell you right now that is not what
they're interested i've actually never
seen a question
that doesn't mean that doesn't exist but
i've never seen a question that is that
is that cruel to you okay for all
intents and purposes when they say
that three appears they mean the three
is on top
okay find the probability that some of
the uppermost faces is greater than
seven okay now this is tricky because of
interpretation
it's even more tricky when you find out
that the answer is 4 and 11.
you're like 11.
like it's hold on hold on it's a
multi-stage event
right so i'm going to be multiplying two
probabilities together the one in the
other
but this this sucker's prime how on
earth do you get 11 out of there
okay now 11 actually pops out quite
easily when you see it you'll be like oh
right but to try and get us there i want
to pose this question to you
when we have probability questions there
are three and only three ways really
of illustrating the probability that's
happening and then being able to pick
out favorable outcomes
sample space okay what are the three
ways
the simplest way
to get the sample so you just list it
just list it you're like for instance
you know if it's if it's rolling one die
you say one two three four five six
i listed them there you go they're all
there okay listing is the first way
what's the other way
second way diagrams and then the way
that we've been dwelling on most
has been on probability trees right
okay now here's the thing and i haven't
done all this very much but
a couple of people have come to me with
questions like this trees on their own
are a tricky tool to use okay because
you know you can draw lots of different
kinds of trees for different questions
some trees are more helpful than others
and so on and so on what i haven't spent
much time on
is the fact that sometimes a dot diagram
for its simplicity
is the necessary first step to get to a
good tree or sometimes
even the diagram itself will be
sufficient for you okay
now when i look at this scenario i read
it again i know that this
is a candidate for a dot diagram because
number one
how many stages are there to the event
two
so that's good that diagram can handle
that um
the second thing is what's the
likelihood of each of the events that
i'm going to get
and the answer is they're all even
nothing is skewing me towards one way
or another right the die as far as i can
the dice as far as i can tell are fair
okay so therefore when i draw up this
thing
you know trees excel when you've got
different numbers on all the branches
right but i won't need to have different
numbers here
all right let's have a go at this two
dice what's the sample space well
you've got one two three four five six
and then you've got one two three four
five
six okay i'm just very quickly going to
do the dots one two three four
six and you can see pretty quickly
that there are going to be how many
total outcomes what's the sample space
36 right 36
right wrong read the question again
a three appears on at least
one of the ice so now i
started with 36 options but i don't
really have 36 options
i have these options a three appears in
all of those
i also have these options a three
appears
in all of those now this looks to me
when i want to know the size of the
sample space
two rows of six minus an overlap
sounds like 11 to me okay
now from there the rest of it falls out
doesn't it what they want is
the sum to be greater than seven so now
instead of dots i'll put in
sums for instance this sum is nine eight
seven that's a dud i'm not gonna bother
going any further
over here i've also got nine eight
seven that's a dud i'm not gonna bother
now i can see that the favorable
outcomes there's
one two three fours
so don't ignore the humble diagram
very useful okay um admittedly
you see the problem is there's no big
flashing light that says to you aha
conditional probability right the
closest thing is when it says
you know a three appears on at least
one of the dice sometimes the other
phrasing that you will see in questions
is
it is known that a three is on one of
the dice
so there's a condition a condition
conditions limit the sample space you
don't have 36 anymore
you just have 11.